en tranquilidad y con baja participación
fueron realizadas las elecciones
parlamentarias en venezuela 20 millones
de ciudadanos fueron llamados a
participar en unos cuestionados comicios
que no cuentan con participación de
partidos de la oposición y también son
rechazados por diferentes sectores
políticos por falta de garantías
democráticas
estos comicios legislativos en venezuela
cuenta con un récord de aspirantes
14.400 candidatos intentan obtener uno
de los doscientos setenta y siete
escaños que conforman esa asamblea
nacional un órgano político que será
elegido en unos comicios que no tienen
reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional se lo explicamos en unos
minutos
a sus 80 años y víctimas del cáncer de
pulmón falleció el ex presidente de
uruguay tabaré vázquez quien se
convirtió en el primer mandatario de
izquierda en gobernar ese país
suramericano el gobierno decretó tres
días de luto nacional y ordenó que las
banderas ondeen a media asta en toda la
república oriental del uruguay
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora 20 millones de ciudadanos
venezolanos fueron convocados para las
elecciones legislativas que no cuentan
con el reconocimiento internacional y
son rechazadas también por los partidos
de oposición que no pudo participar la
jornada contó con una reducida
participación ciudadana y sin
alteraciones en el orden público estos
comicios servirán para renovar a partir
del 5 de enero los 277 escaños que
tendrá la asamblea nacional que es hasta
ahora el único poder político en manos
de la oposición y que a partir de la
nueva legislatura que comenzará como
decíamos a partir del 5 de enero del
podría pasar a ser controlada por
completo por el oficialista partido
socialista unido de venezuela el psoe
vamos a saludar a línea fernández
nuestra corresponsal en caracas para
conocer más detalles de esta jornada muy
buenas noches allí en la capital
venezolana herminia cuál es el resumen
de esta jornada las urnas están cerrando
hace algunos minutos cerraron cuál es el
resumen y el balance de esta jornada
electoral en venezuela
sí buenas noches santiago fue una escasa
participación según un recorrido que
hizo france24 durante todo el día desde
el oeste hasta el este de la capital la
verdad que hubo muy poca participación
comparado a otras elecciones también se
vio que quienes acudieron a votar en su
mayoría digamos el casi el total de los
que salieron a votar iban a votar por el
partido de gobierno y sus aliados el
consejo nacional electoral extendió el
cierre de urnas de por una hora más e
insistió a las autoridades y los
miembros de mesa que no pueden cerrar
hasta que no haya el último votante
mientras esto ocurre el partido del
gobierno es digamos lo que su campaña a
la parte de la campaña electoral está
insistiendo por los medios de
comunicación llamando a sus seguidores
que salgan a votar todavía que tienen
tiempo para que hagan lo que ellos
llaman el remate perfecto
herminia ya como lo habíamos dicho los
partidos de la oposición no tuvieron
participación en estos comicios
legislativos prácticamente los
candidatos que hay representan algunas
fuerzas del chavismo unos más cercanos a
nicolás maduró otros no tanto como
estará entonces conformada esta posible
nueva asamblea nacional y pues como será
entonces el escenario político con ese
triunfo del chavismo en este órgano
legislativo
si hoy se están eligiendo doscientos
setenta y siete escaños anteriormente
eran 167 son 111 más esto lo decidió el
consejo nacional electoral diciendo que
había crecido la población y que había
que hacerlo los analistas estiman que
por la extensión que se vaya a dar el
día de hoy que calculan que esté por el
70 por ciento el chavismo y sus aliados
se apoderarían de unos 215 escaños lo
cual significaría de estos 177 lo cual
significaría que obtendría una mayoría
absoluta
nicolás maduro llamó a todo su personal
oa todas las personas más cercanas a él
para que se lanzaran a candidatos entre
eso su esposa su hijo también ocho
ministros renunciaron para ir como
candidatos del partido socialista unido
de venezuela también de diputados que
eran de la asamblea nacional
constituyente todo esto en pro de poder
lograr el máximo poder y retomar de
nuevo la asamblea nacional
el mini a también lo mencionábamos la
comunidad internacional ya dijo que no
va a reconocer estos comicios organismos
como por ejemplo la unión europea han
sido enfáticos en no reconocer a este
proceso por carecer de garantías
democráticas esto entonces en la
práctica en que se traduce qué medidas
pueden verse reflejadas en la práctica y
cuál será el papel entonces que tendrá
juan guaidó que es el presidente de la
asamblea nacional que termina la
legislatura y también es el presidente
de venezuela reconocido por 50 países a
nivel mundial
sí como ya lo dijiste de antemano ya la
unión europea eeuu dijeron que no lo van
a reconocer la unión europea de hecho
pidió que se digamos se suspendieran o
que por lo menos se les fuese hiciera
una fecha más adelantada pero el
gobierno de nicolás maduro no lo aceptó
hoy el ex presidente español rodríguez
zapatero señalaba en los medios de
comunicación venezolanos le decía a la
unión europea y eeuu y el resto de la
comunidad internacional que tenían que
cómo se va a apoyar a estas elecciones y
les decía que era apoyar al pueblo
venezolana esto va a pasar lo mismo que
en el 2018 que la comunidad
internacional no apoyó a nicolás maduro
como presidente y va a pasar lo mismo
con esta asamblea nacional es la segunda
vez que la comunidad internacional
rechaza un proceso electoral en
venezuela herminia muchas gracias por
este completo reporte desde caracas y
estaremos atentos al conteo de los votos
que debe comenzar en las próximas horas
allí en venezuela mientras tanto vamos a
informarles sobre otros hechos
destacados del día falleció a sus 80
años víctima de cáncer de pulmón el ex
presidente de
república oriental del uruguay tabaré
vázquez quien fuera el líder del partido
frente amplio
vázquez destacado político en su país
era médico oncólogo de profesión y se
convirtió en 2004 en el primer
presidente de un partido de izquierda en
gobernar en uruguay el gobierno decretó
tres días de luto nacional y también
ordenó que todas las banderas incluidas
las que están en las instituciones
públicas uruguayas ondeen a media asta
festejen uruguayos festejen que la
victoria es de ustedes en octubre de
tabaré vázquez consiguió su primera
victoria a las elecciones presidenciales
y se dirigía de esta forma a la multitud
que lo ovacionaba en montevideo con su
victoria la izquierda llegó por primera
vez al poder en la historia de uruguay
en 2015 vázquez alcanzaría de nuevo la
presidencia del país y creo que hay
frente amplio- para rato muchas
generaciones más si sigues y creo que el
uruguayo muy inteligente y mi nieto lo
van a ver también gobiernos progresistas
la mañana de este domingo 6 de diciembre
uruguay se ha despertado con la triste
noticia de la muerte de tabaré vázquez
de 80 años a causa de un cáncer de
pulmón detectado en agosto de 2019 el ex
presidente se crió en el humilde barrio
de la teja en montevideo desde donde
llegó a la universidad para
especializarse en oncología en 1989 ganó
las elecciones a la intendencia de
montevideo y se convirtió en el primer
gobernante de la historia de la
coalición de izquierda frente amplio
con profundo dolor comunicamos el
fallecimiento de nuestro presidente de
honor
tabaré vázquez su ejemplo de integridad
política y compromiso inquebrantable con
nuestro país y la gente nos impulsará a
continuar su legado tras 2004 su
presidencia estuvo marcada por su
preocupación por la salud y la lucha
contra la industria tabacalera en el
recuerdo queda el litigio con la
poderosa multinacional philip morris su
veto en 2008 a la despenalización del
aborto y el célebre caso del ex militar
josé gavazzo de presunto ocultamiento de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
durante la dictadura de 1973 a 1985
quedan como principal sombra de sus dos
mandatos presidenciales además de la
política y sus dos grandes pasiones
fueron el fútbol y la medicina y será
recordado como el político que llevó a
la izquierda al poder por primera vez en
la pequeña nación suramericana la unión
europea y el reino unido- hacen los
últimos esfuerzos posibles para
concretar un acuerdo post exit que está
estancado por discrepancias en cuanto a
equilibrio de relaciones
londres bruselas gobernanza y los temas
de
los jefes negociadores se reanudarán las
conversaciones en bruselas el lunes para
alcanzar un punto en común las partes
tienen hasta el 31 de diciembre de 2020
para llegar a un acuerdo y evitar el
llamado pre éxito lo que implicaría la
imposición de aranceles entre otras
medidas
y para el cierre les mostramos estas
imágenes del cohete falcon 9 de la
compañía aeroespacial privada space ex
que fue lanzado este domingo para llevar
una cápsula con provisiones para el
equipo científico que está en la
estación espacial internacional el
cohete fue lanzado desde el centro
espacial kennedy de la nasa en cabo
cañaveral en florida ya esta hora
mantiene su rumbo sin contratiempo hacia
la estación espacial internacional con
estas imágenes los dejamos aquí en el
informativo de france 24